from timcast.com two explosions
registered near nordstream pipelines
causing gas to leak in Baltic Sea a
senior Ukrainian official accused Russia
of the explosions calling them an act of
terrorism now you may have noticed we
titled this show us accused and that's
because online what you're seeing pop up
all over Twitter and on social media is
a video of Joe Biden saying that the U.S
was going to take this action I think
it's it's obvious that Russia is being
accused of doing this but my issue right
there is we could we could type we could
structure the story and frame it a
certain way we can say U.S accused which
we chose to do we could say Russia
accused which I feel kind of makes no
sense or we could say both U.S and
Russia separately accused of of state of
engaging in sabotage the issue I take
with this is that if Russia were to have
been the one that detonated explosion
that detonated some device blowing up
the pipeline it's a false flag attack
and I don't think that's the simple
solution I think it's more likely that
we have this story right here check this
out this is from February 8th if Russia
invades Ukraine there will be no
nordstream 2 Biden says I mean he just
outright he says it and then he smirks
when he's asked by a reporter well how
would you do anything about it you have
no control and he says I promise you
there will be no nordstring pipeline
then we learn about an operation ball
tops 22 U.S Navy uh Navy's sixth fleet
was doing exercises with uh mind
detection and mock explosives near born
home Denmark which is where the
explosions happened now no matter how
you cut it we got a conspiracy who did
it why did they do it I don't think it
actually matters the U.S some people
think they did it because Biden said he
was gonna he's basically said there
would be no pipeline but Russia they
could they could stage a false flag to
try and boost morale because they're
conscripting people and they need people
willing and happy to fight so which is
it I think you made a good point that
it's one of the more valuable assets to
destroy that wouldn't make a lot of
sense like Pearl Harbor whether or not
you think it was a false flag some
people think it was in the case that
they didn't know they were going to get
attacked in Pearl Harbor but they let it
happen anyway they didn't know exactly
where or when but they had five aircraft
carriers out of port or a bunch of four
of their five aircraft or something if
the aircraft carriers had been at Pearl
Harbor and they've been sunk Japan would
have invaded San Francisco next so the
US was ready for Pearl Harbor whether or
not it seemed like it
so why is Hawaii's decently far away but
I don't know about San Francisco well if
we didn't have the aircraft carriers to
defend the Japanese would have
controlled the Pacific after that battle
so also with any event you got to ask
yourself who really benefits here but
even Beyond going the speculation here I
think a lot of the other comments made
by other prominent politicians
absolutely matter here the Danish Prime
Minister said that it's quote hard to
imagine that this is accidental the
Polish prime minister said that this was
an act of sabotage and now the former
Ministry of defense for Poland sent out
a message on Twitter saying thank you
USA with a picture of of course the the
pipeline that of course busted it's
possible Denmark so there's a lot of
crazy stuff happening Ukraine is blaming
Russia Russia is blaming the West who's
responsible here we do not know but this
is going to guarantee a dark winter in
Europe Europe is already in a major
energy crisis this guarantees very
severe problems ahead of us that are
going to be very impactful for the
average people for the poorest people in
Europe that are going to be devastated
by this who who is this guy it's a radek
circus circus Sikorski sorry and I
believe uh he's a member of European
Parliament chairman EU USA delegation
uh I'm not sure exactly I I heard he's
from Poland you know he is I think he's
the former Ministry of defense is that
yeah I don't know this guy right here
Reddick Sikorski says thank you USA he's
verified on Twitter as a member of
European Parliament
um yeah the USA is probably the one that
did it or whoever's it's just like
there's no way I I seriously doubt
Russia you might stage a false flag to
get people to go to war but when you're
already in war it's pretty I mean it's
not off the impossible that you would
say it's a false flag to get people to
go do something within the war but also
specifically there is blow up your own
frequency there was forewarning that
this was going to happen according to
Reuters the CIA was warning Berlin about
the possibility on attacks on these
pipelines the summer of this year so the
CIA knew this was happening there was
war games this Tim was talking about I I
think again you got to ask yourself who
does this benefit this stops the
possibility of another bargaining chips
this stops the possibility of
negotiations this stops the possibility
of Europe having energy this stops the
possibility of what a lot of people are
calling the great reset that of course
is being only going to be pushed forward
by this latest action this is the crazy
thing right we've got Russia invading
Ukraine which means fertilizer shortages
food shortages so naturally what do the
nether what does the Netherlands do they
instruct their Farmers to stop farming
well that makes a whole lot of sense
doesn't it Netherlands I believe is the
second biggest exporter of food in it
could be it could be in the world I
might be wrong about that and they're
being the farmers are being told to stop
farming over climate change now you've
got the nordstream pipeline was already
shut down there's two there's Nordstrom
one and two they were not delivering
Russia shut down deliveries in beginning
of September and said indefinitely
why would Russia blow up a pipeline
they've already cut off access to
I suppose you make the argument they
want to be like hey look we're being
attacked quick everybody come fight on
our on our behalf the U.S bragged about
it but more importantly to get look no
matter which way you cut it there's a
conspiracy here either it was the U.S it
was Russia it was who knows right
but there's also the dark winter as Luke
mentioned this guarantees there will be
no negotiating with Russia to reopen
Europe will not be able to be pressured
into succumbing to the whims of Russia
think about this way
winter comes pipeline is shut off
Germany says to Russia we will do
anything we are freezing we need the
energy and Russia says stop the support
for Ukraine and they say anything you
say turns the switch gas flows back into
Europe let's say the CIA or whoever who
knows the U.S blows up the pipeline or
damage it damages it to such a degree it
will not be able to provide resources
they can't up the pressure they can't
set the flow it'll leak out in the
Baltic now Germany will not be able to
go to Russia and beg because Russia has
nothing to offer the only outcome now is
they have to keep supporting the war
there's other pipelines too going from
Russia into Europe some of them also are
go from Russia to Turkey but it's also
important to note here that a lot of the
other pipelines go through Ukraine so
it's it's in a battlefield right now
there's a lot of things at stake here
Timothy what are you doing here
Andrew what do you think who do you
think's responsible here geopolitically
how do you think this is going to play
out from here
is there something different about you
the glasses I'm telling you it's the
glasses
I just cannot put my finger on it might
be a new shirt I am I'm uh I'm just
hypnotized
I don't know hey I have hair looks a
little lighter well so so and look guys
I know I know you all think Luke is
handsome and beautiful but thank you but
Andrew what are your thoughts on this I
mean we've been kind of going off what
do you think I've just been listening
it's very it's very informative uh I
like all your takes uh and well look
I we don't know how extensive the damage
is we don't know
uh
I mean I I do agree that with Russia uh
needing needing troops that if if they
did do this or if they didn't do this
they have Joe Biden basically saying I'm
gonna do it so so right right he said
this in February
right well he said there will be no
Nordstrom too right they didn't like
this is a leak you're right we don't
know the extent of the damage right we
don't know how how quickly can be fixed
yes right but the spread is a kilometer
what the the so we have this picture
right of the of the leak that's a
kilometer is it leaking gas yes those
are bubbles so here's here's a cool
thing a science lesson for all you for
all you nerds uh when there is a release
of gas rapidly it breaks apart surface
tension basically there's no uh buoyancy
because the water is being pushed apart
if a ship goes over it it will just drop
straight down like a hole is it like
like air gas you said they shut
naturally shut it off oh so there was
like residual methane they're still in
it and the pressure drops like it's
still it's still pressure now it's all
leaking yeah fixing that thing sounds
like an utter nightmare we're dealing
with tremendous pressure down below I
actually did a poll on my YouTube
channel asking people who do you think
is really responsible for this explosion
on the North stream pipeline 71 percent
of of people out of ten thousand voters
voted and said that the United States
did it twelve percent said Russia did it
five percent said it was a legit
accident accident and 12 percent said
other foreign countries did it so uh
obviously a lot of people were thinking
that it was not Russia who did this to
themselves well maybe it was climate
change
things the water temperature changed so
fast that it caused a rapid expansion
and contraction of the pipe causing it
to bend and bursts and if those damn
Republicans would have voted for climate
change funding this would have never
happened did you see that video of the
woman in her car and she's like I just
paid 94 for gas 94 dollars
I guess
and then like she's ranting and I'm I'm
for a while I'm going like I'm with you
like I'm upset about this and then she
goes the religious right did this and
then I was just like well hold on there
a minute say what I don't understand how
you go from I guess it's too expensive
to Christian's bed I just I don't I'm
like the religious right they're the
ones saying drill baby drill you know
what I mean you guys think if we seeded
this land of Russia this eastern Ukraine
and the freeways and stuff that they
would stop invading or is it like a
Neville Chamberlain thing where they
gave Hitler a little bit of the sudanity
no they uh I I've been saying this for a
long time I think that and at this point
it's probably way too late to negotiate
properly but uh the dunbars like you
know eastern Ukraine they they should
have just said it was it was basically
under Russian control anyway
so they might as well just said just
just take it let's take it and that's it
and and they probably would have and
then we won't go to Nato but there was a
peace deal earlier this year where the
Russians said we won't take any of your
land you just don't sign up to Nato you
don't join the European Union and the
ukrainians and the Russians were were
agreeing to this and then Boris Johnson
flew to Ukraine and said no you don't
agree to the peace deal here and and
then there would have been no succeeding
to any land Russia wouldn't have taken
any additional land and there would have
been the truth but but of course Western
Powers pushed against that because give
them money like how how much are we in
the hole now 100 what's 60 billion 68
billion
I gotta make a point Ian you said uh is
it gonna be like Hitler in the Sudan
land you're saying right yeah like if we
see this land to Russia they'll keep
expanding yeah that's what they thought
of the two factions Russia and NATO
which one's been expanding in Europe
exactly NATO exactly so right now the
issue is not the like you comparing uh
Putin to Hitler is just a political well
Putin also took uh Crimea and there was
also a lot of tensions and land grabs in
Georgia so so there are some arguments
that you could you could make there
again I'm not a fan of any government we
need to see these issues from both sides
as from the arguments that are being
made here in order to try to push for a
bigger resolution here because all we're
seeing is escalation escalation
escalation and the bargaining chip today
was taken off the table that was a major
one that could have resolved a lot of
these problems that could have ended the
war that could have brought people cheap
energy and would have helped people
prosper during these very difficult
times which are being deliberately
engineered according to my own personal
opinion in order to push a larger agenda
of suffering on the rest of the
population translation you're saying
that the United States did it no I'm
saying here's what it could be even
beyond that it could be a clandestine
organization outside of the United
States that has an invested interest a
rogue Nation it could be a corporation
heroic intelligence agency Tom Cruise it
could be a rogue intelligence agency
that could have an invested interest in
saying hey we could sell a lot of
weapons here hey we could profit off of
the great reset hey we could we can make
a lot of money off of freezing Europe
and easily make it look like it was the
us because Biden says stupid things on
TV yeah we're living in a world where
multinational corporations have a lot
more power than governments and we have
to understand this reality especially
when it comes to shaping world events
staging them and of course manipulating
them in our current Society let's let's
pull this next story because here's
here's what's being reported in the
Press Daily Mail says did Putin's frog
men blow up Europe's gas supplies
Western leaders blame deliberate
sabotage after Nord stream pipe from
Russia ruptured off Sweden causing three
thousand foot wide Bubbles and sending
prices spiking three leaks were reported
in Nordstrom one and two near the Danish
Islands last night pipelines are leaking
gas from the Baltic so we covered a lot
of this the question is was it Moscow
they're claiming that it was his frog
man but what they don't ever put in
these stories is why would Russia blow
up their own means of selling gas into
Europe I don't understand but also it
not much sense how much explosives would
you need like how much how much do you
do these frog men not carry really it's
only a few inches of concrete still
reinforced concrete and then I think
it's a 1.6 inch steel so theoretically a
very small device could get the job done
okay yep so here's my question prices
are spiking you know there's a group of
people that have been advocating for for
the the stoppage of fossil fuels for a
long time and these are Western
organizations so I just think it's very
strange that Joe Biden's whole agenda is
around he says we're going to end fossil
fuels he shuts down uh he shuts down us
I promise you
there's gonna be no Nordstrom Pipeline
and I'm kind of like could there be an
element of the great reset
because this is the point I'm trying to
make why would the Netherlands tell
their Farmers to stop making food when
the the world was it the World Health
Organization is estimating hundreds of
millions will starve to death because of
the war in Ukraine and because of covid
now is the time to tell the farmers in
Netherlands you need to make more food
now is the time to be doing everything
possible to avoid nuclear war and to get
energy into Europe when the prices are
spiking I mean Germany is seeing
inflation at like 45 percent the
Sterling and the and the Euro have
dropped to Dollar parity but when you
see those things happen I can't help but
say they're stopping the use of fossil
fuels
they're telling Farmers stop farming and
now the economic crisis has brought
parity to the dollar the pound and the
Euro that's a that's that's the great
reset wet dream that Klaus Schwab is
probably you know let's just say he's
he's enjoying himself to put it mildly
yeah energy is being limited it's
becoming a artificially a scarcity
because it will bring up economic
upheaval that of course the central
Bankers are awaiting as an excuse to
bring in their Central Banking digital
currencies which of course the the many
central banks many federal reserves have
announced today that they're of course
pushing for that they're of course that
they want that of course is going to
create also why isn't anyone taking me
seriously why is everyone smiling when
I'm talking
it's hard to take Luke seriously when he
looks like Mrs Doubtfire why would they
say that I don't know Robin Williams
anyway what's
your I think is is deliberate I think
it's gonna mean a lot of trouble for a
lot of individuals a lot of suffering
stop laughing Andrew
eyes up here oh my God and and and and
and how this is going to play out is
really not going to be in anyone's
benefit I think you made a really good
point that it could be corporations dude
multinational corporations unaccountable
corporations and and and you know things
out of the military industrial complex
that that are private entities that
could get away with things that
government agencies can't so I've been
thinking if there is a global Revolution
man it's going to be against corporate
corporate like technocracy
huh what Sledge we're playing we're
playing charades Sledgehammer
technocracy yeah International corporate
technocracy is like my my main fear I'm
not worried about the Russians I'm not
worried about the Chinese I'm worried
about and of course I'm worried about
governments colluding with multinational
corporations but
you know I don't want technological
slavery foist on the people without them
realizing it let's pull up this map here
because this is what's going on here in
in over in Europe Russia's got a bunch
of pipelines going into Europe and they
basically control the flow of natural
gas gas problem has it all it's not just
Ukraine they've got uh two pipelines
going in looks like they have multiple
pipelines going into turkey they come up
it back into Europe they've got transgas
there's yamal Europe there's the
northern lights and then Nordstrom is
bringing it into Germany several of
these pipelines are going into Germany
nordstream it looks like also connects
uh the BBL into the UK
there's a what I don't understand is
Russia
I guess destroying the pipeline stops
the flow of energy but Russia's trying
to sell this stuff into Europe so it I
don't know man uh what's what's the
outcome here is it world war three is it
is I mean Russia is going to blame the
U.S hands down how do you think this is
going to play out Andrew
well
I cover a lot of domestic stuff in my
channel so I'm really not the foreign
policy expert like Joe Biden is you know
I mean he's
he he knows what he's doing he you know
he's fine we're gonna be everything's
gonna be fine because Joe Biden is back
America is back so I saw these I'm sorry
I'm just so
uh distracted
by dirt
your damn shirt Luke they're great sure
they're they're great quality they're
amazing shirts they're amazing so I was
watching uh uh I was looking at some of
the photos coming out of Florida we got
hurricane Ian yes just ripping through
and already all the store shelves are
completely barren
people went in and they bought
everything up at the last minute
I look at that kind of stuff and I'm
like with what we're seeing now in
Europe I mean this is this is
they're saying sabotage people need to
understand how serious this is this is
this is a direct Act of War whoever did
this if it was some Rogue group if in
fact it wasn't an accident or or some
kind of uh flaw I think it was three
separate explosions is what I read
earlier but but were they in in two it's
completely separate areas or were they
each other two areas like I'm talking
about area not not in in the amount of
time you know like there was one in ten
minutes there were a few hours later I
believe okay yeah all right so what were
they in the same morning and then five
in the morning but were they in the same
vicinity no okay they're close to each
other enough to where you're getting one
big gas spread but okay so we don't know
but it's in the it's in an area where
the US Navy was conducting weird
operations I'm just saying outside of
that the reason I bring up the hurricane
stuff and the supply uh loss of supplies
is
I guess it all just comes back to we can
bring it bring it back to the domestic
policy stuff you know people in big
cities are going to be doomed if if this
really does escalate beyond what just
what it is now and it's looking like it
Europe's screwed and all of these weird
woke European people now I mean we're
seeing Italy and we're seeing the right
start to win again but there's a lot of
woke craziness in Europe just like in
the United States what do you think is
going to happen to these people there's
no gas for winter they're they're not
going to have food they're not preparing
for this these people live the utmost
luxury like capital city and Hunger
Games and they have no idea what's in
store for them and I'll say the same for
people in the U.S when the hurricane
comes it's coming when the hurricane
started coming even Miami was getting
hit even though it's not in the direct
path like there's flooding there's a
video of a sewer lid popping off and
people are rushing to stores at the last
minute like oh no I don't know what to
buy these people have done no research
on what they need to do to survive their
skills are not suited for these kinds of
disasters and it seems like no matter
what there's just more and more disaster
happening around the planet you got
escalation of War what have happens when
it when when this results in major
economic collapse here in the U.S
because seeing what happens to the pound
and the Euro that's going to Ripple
across and hit us too when these
countries have no demand for U.S dollars
because they're well actually maybe the
opposite will happen maybe the
destruction of the North Street pipeline
makes them desperate for oil and they
have no choice but to buy US dollars
from us but their currency is now
worthless we're basically going to own
Europe
yep and if if there ever was a way to
create a cashless Society this this this
would be it and as we know according to
the world economic Forum they want to
create a carbon social credit score and
and I think a lot of this plays into it
and I think the the financial Calamity
that we're seeing is deliberate I think
energy exploration production has been
deliberately brought down by a lot of
these policies to make the weather
better but in reality it's not making
the weather better it's actually causing
more pollution in many instances causing
a lot of suffering and again you limit
energy to the population you limit
prosperity of the population so there's
a correlation between both lack of
energy lack of prosperity for
individuals to actually do things in
life to actually buy things in life to
travel places to make and commence
Commerce all of that I think is being
directly targeted and I think we're
seeing the effects of that with the
poorest people in the world becoming a
lot poorer I think that's only going to
progress even further I think the people
in Europe are going to spend their
savings on heating their homes on trying
to keep their business is open if they
can because a lot of the times many of
these businesses will have to shut down
because the operating costs the taxes
the regulations Just Simply Having the
heat on in your business will be too
expensive for the average person to be
even able to afford it no you go to jail
exactly well in uh yeah Switzerland is
is even advertising saying hey if if
your neighbor is heating their home past
66 degrees you better tell us because
you will face a major fine you can even
face jail time if you can't pay the fine
and you know we're learning to eat your
home you know we learned from covet
they'll do it you know your neighbors
will rat you out in Canada for during
World War One there's propaganda where
it's like do not hoard if you have more
than one bag of flour it's illegal and
they would come and arrest they'd look
for you and arrest you if you were
hoarding so I could have you know we
gotta watch out that they start don't
start hunting people down for hoarding
food
you know because people have been
stocking up well with a crisis that's
being engineered what's scarcity that's
being engineered you could get away with
emergency protocols emergency laws
emergency uh actions because whenever
you give government power during
emergencies eventually government will
start creating emergencies that's the
train of thinking that I come from
that's my own personal opinion and I
think we saw a lot what happened with
with kovid that is very alarming that
did show a lot of people that didn't see
an alternative point of view that didn't
question things that just accepted it
because it was the only thing that they
saw social media went along with that
they censored certain ideas they certain
they censored certain scientists they
censored individuals who were speaking
out some of them were even arrested some
of them were even debanked in places
like Canada for daring to speak out
against the current status quo against
the system that of course was telling
people that they couldn't even go
outside of their homes Australia you
couldn't even go down the street you
couldn't walk away from your house you
would end up in a a coveted Camp which
is absolutely crazy thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there